Dre Quach, bonsoir.
Comment allez-vous?
- Bonsoir. Ça va, merci.
Et vous?
- Très bien, très bien. Alors,
vous me l'aviez déjà dit, mais
vous, vous êtes... non seulement
vous êtes à l'aise avec
la réouverture lundi,
mais il fallait faire ça
pour le bien-être des enfants.
- Oui, tout à fait. Je pense que
quand on regarde les avantages
et les inconvénients de la
réouverture des écoles, c'est
sûr qu'il y a uù on
peut se dire : est-ce qu'il va
y avoir plus de transmission
de COVID? Dans les éléments
qu'on a besoin de tenir en
compte, c'est que les enfants
sont peut que,
par ailleurs, je pense
qu'il y en a déjà pas mal qui
ont eu la COVID, mais d'un point
de vue scolarisation, réussite
scolaire, développement,
ation, ils sont bien
plus heureux à l'école que
derrière leur tablette
ou leur écran d'ordinateur.
- Docteur Boileau, tout à
l'heure, et d'autres, on entends
dire : ce n'est pas comme la
COVID du Delta, c'est différent
et on doit donc ajuster nos
protocoles de retour. Quand
quelqu'un a eu la COVID dans une
classe, on ne doit plus fermer
toute la classe. Les gens
qui ont été en contact peuvent
retourner à l'école s'ils n'ont
pas de set, aprèet, aprèet, aprq
jours, la personne malade doit,
peut revenir. Ça, ça vous semble
raisonnable aussi d'assouplir
tout ce protocole qui était
quand même assez lourd?
- Je penme ce qu'on
voit présentement, c'est que
l'Omicron est quand même 50 %
moins virulent que le Delta,
qu'encore une fois, les enfants
se portent bien avec la COVID,
qu'il y en a beaucedans
qui sont même asymptomatiques,
c'est à se dire que quand il y a
déjà un cas dans la classe, même
si on fermait la classe, on les
retirait tous, il y a déjà eu
une certaine contagion.C'est una
varicelle où, je ne sais pas
si vous vous rappelez, quand
on était jeune, on faisait la
varicelle, on nous retirait de
la classe pendant une semain
on avait droit à une semaine
de congés à la maison, mais
aujourd'hui, les enfants ont la
varicelle, ils restent à l'école
parce que, comme la transmission
s'est déjà faite avant
l'apparition des boutons,
il n'y a plus vraiment davantage
à retirer l'enfant par la suite.
Donc, c'est un peu cette
réflexion-là qu'il faut faire et
aussi parce qu'évet,
il va falloir apprendre à vivre
avec ce virus, il est là pour
rester, sous une forme ou une
autre. Et compte tenu de tout ça
et du besoin que ces enfants-là
cole,
je pense que les décisions
sont bien prises.
- Votre collègue Dr Weiss, hier,
a dit à cette émission... parce
que ça revient beaucoup dans lee
dans un autre champ de votre
expertise, la vaccination, il a
dit : "Ceux qui ont contracté la
maladie et qui sont adéquatement
vaccinés, qui ont déjà deuxdoses
nécessairement pour la troisième
dose, vous pouvez attendre
un peu, d'autant qu'il y a
de nouveaux vaccins qui vont
arriver. Pour les enfants qui
ont eu une première dose, donc,
par exemple de 8 ans, 9 ans,
10 ans, qui ont eu une première
dose et qui ont fa
après, est-ce que vous êtes,
vous, du même avis qu'il est
préférable d'attendre un peu
pour la deuxième dose pour
les enfants?
- En fait, ce qu'on dit
toujours, c'est quand on vient
de faireon, notreon, notreon, ne
système immunitaire est à son
maximum, on est protégé
contre le virus qu'on vient
de combattre et donc qu'il n'y a
pas vraiment d'avantage à aller
chercher la vaccination tout
de suite. Je vous dirais que
l'enjeu un peu plus logistique
isationnelisationnelisationnelie
savoir : est-ce que notre enfant
a fait la COVID ou
Parce qu'avant Noël, ça allait,
la plupart des enfants qui
avaient fait la COVID avaient
un PCR positif ou avaient
un contact direct avec un PCR
depuis une
semaine et demie, ça devient
hyper difficile de confirmer
l'infection et, donc, on n'est
pas trop sûr, si notre enfant
a été un peu malade, est-ce quet
un autre virus, et c'est dans ce
contexte où on se dit :
si on ne le sait pas, il n'y a
pas vraiment de danger à a
chercher notre deuxième dose
alors qu'elle était prévue, mais
si on a une confirmation que
c'était bel et bien la COVID par
PCR, on peut absolument atte
quatre à huit semaines avant
d'aller chercher la dose de
rappel.
- Bon, et pour les plus vieux,
pour la troisième dose, vous
êtes aussi d'accord avec Docteur
Weiss qu
précipitation à y avoir non plus
pour la dose de rappel quand on
est adulte et on a fait la
COVID.
- Absolument. En fait, la
décision du comité sur
l'immunisation du Québec,
c'était ça, c'était de dire que
deux vaccideux vaccideux vaccids
et une infection, la troisième
dose n'était pas nécessaire,
mais si jamais on la voulait,
idéalement, on attendait de moi
n avant d'aller
la chercher. Mais on comprend...
Encore une fois, ça ne veut pas
dire que toutes les COVID ont
été confirmées, ça veut pas dirs
tests, et c'est dans ce contexte
là où le gouvernement a décidé
de dire : pour des raisons
d'équité, s'il n'est pas tropsûe
aller la chercher à la fin de
vos symptômes.
- En fait, ce que je comprends,
c'est que c'est pour des raisons
de communication aussi, de
simplicité, vous dites, que le
gouvernement a dit : allez-y
pour la troisième dose. Parce
qu'il n'y a pas non plus dedange
troisième dose si on a eu la
COVID. C'est juste que vous
dites : c'est inutile, vous êtes
déjà protégé.
- Exact, c'est inutile, on est
très bi
l'infection protège de façon
beaucoup plus large qu'une dose
de vaccin et, habituellement, la
protection suite à l'infection
dure plus longtemps qu'une dose
de vaccin. Donc tout ça mis
aucun
bénéfice direct à aller chercher
une troisième dose quand on
vient de faire la COVID.
- Bon, là, je pense que c'est
clair, clair, clair. Très bien.
Est-ce que... vous voyez leses,s
aussi, quand vous étudiez, vous
voyez qu'on est arrivé au fameux
sommet de cette courbe?de compts
infections que ça devient très
difficile parce que, encore une
fois, on a moins accès à des
tests. Quand on regarde, elle a
l'air de s'aplatir. Il va
falloir voir si les
hospitalisations, la courbe des
hospitalisations s
aussi. Je pense que ça va être
ça, notre meilleur indicateur.
Mais dans différentes
juridictions, dans le nord-est
des États-Unis
qu'il semble y avoir un
ralentissement de l'augmentation
des hospitalisations et des
Et donc ça, je pense que c'est
de bon augure. Ça fait un mois,
un mois et demi à peu près qu'on
est là-dedans et, donc, on
devrait
plateau.
- Et l'immunité co
en parle moins, mais comme il y
a beaucoup, beaucoup de gens qui
l'ont contracté, la COVID, ça
aide, par ailleurs.
- J'ai manqué un bout parce que
mon bouchon était sorti...
- Excusez-moi, j'ai dit que
l'immunité collective dont on
parle moins, le fait qu'il y a
beaucoup plus de gens qui ont
contracté le virus, ça aide.
- Oui, c'est sûr,
ça aide parce qu'à ce moment-là,
on a mis des espèces de murs de
protection entre les gens qui
sont encore à risque et, donc,
plus on aura ses grandes villes
de prote
avoir de transmission
communautaire, donc on espère
qu'on va arriver à une espèce de
protection à tout le moins
partiel. Ce qui est plus, ça vat
que l'Omicron qui se transmet,
donc c'est facile, mais les gens
qui avaient fait l'infraction
dans le passé ou les gens qui
vaccination, même s'ils avaient
une protection partielle, on
n'empêchait pas complètement les
infections, donc on n'empêchait
pas non plus complètement lasios
les plus à risque, donc les
personnes plus âgées, avec des
conditions médicales sous-
jacentes, demeuraient à risque
d'avoir une... si jamais elles
l'attrapaient, d'avoir une COVID
plus compliquée. D
le message, c'est : allez
chercher votre dose là où vous
êtes rendu dans votre protoSi vé
vacciné, faites-vous vacciner.
On le sait, que m
doses, on a une excellente
protection contre les
complications. Et pour ceux qui
sont admissibles à la doserapper
aussi.
- Dre Quach, merci beaucoup
encore une fois. Au revoir.